el círculo x cuadrada malla cuadrada
menos 8 x igual a cero y la hipérbola x
cuadrada sobre 9 menos cuadradas sobre 4
igual a 1 intersectan al punto b y la
ecuación del círculo con ahí ve cuál
diámetro es la siguiente entonces hay
que visualizar el círculo en hipérbola
entonces tenemos que la ecuación del
círculo sería x cuadrada tenemos la
ecuación del círculo x cuadrada massieu
cuadrada menos 8 x espera mejor lo voy a
escribir juntando las x para más
adelante utilizarlo entonces aquí
tenemos ya cuadrada y esto es igual a 0
y podemos agregar de ambas partes 16 y
esto de agregar el 16 es para poder
utilizarlo a la hora de completar el
cuadrado entonces esta parte de aquí se
convierte en el x menos 4 al cuadrado
más que cuadrada y todo esto es igual a
16 ahora bien con dicha información
vamos a formar nuestro círculo este es
el eje de las x nuestro
eje de la siesta y luego tenemos que el
centro está en 1234 en el 40 y el radio
es la raíz de 16 por lr cuadrada y
entonces tenemos que es 4 1 2 3 4 y todo
esto lo estoy haciendo a una mejor
escala para que me quede mejor dibujada
mi circunferencia entonces tenemos que
el círculo marcamos estas nuestros
puntos claves para trazar lo mejor
entonces lo voy a pintar por aquí de
color morado y nos quedaría de la
siguiente forma no soy la mejor
dibujante de círculos pero es para que
quede la idea y luce nuestra si nuestro
círculo algo así lo estoy remarcando
mejor pero bueno luego tenemos la
hipérbola x cuadrada sobre 9 - de
cuadrada sobre 4 igual a 1 y entonces
hay que ver ahora que el término x
cuadrado es positivo y esto nos sirve
para ver que de un lado va a abrir de
forma positiva la hipérbola y ahora
también que checarlo para las 'íes'
entonces tenemos nuestra ecuación y
restando de ambos lados
cuadradas sobre 4 nos queda que es menos
de cuadrado sobre 4 igual a menos x
cuadradas sobre 9 más 1 y luego entonces
podemos multiplicar por 4 ambas partes
de la ecuación x menos 4 perdón para que
quede de la siguiente forma y también a
su vez como queremos dejar libre la jep
podemos sacar raíz de esta ecuación
entonces nos quedaría la raíz cuadrada
de 492 de x cuadrada menos 4 ahora
observemos bien tenemos aquí dos
términos pero este término justo de aquí
enrollando nos está alterando tanto
nuestra ecuación porque cuando x tiende
a infinito este número no afecta al
infinito entonces lo que podríamos hacer
sería dejar simplemente nuestro primer
término quitar el menos 4 que no nos
afecta en lo absoluto ya sacar raíz
ahora sí de cuatro novenas de x cuadrada
tendríamos que es dos tercios d
y ahora trazando dicha dicha recta
tendríamos lo siguiente tenemos por aquí
dos tercios de equis y cuando x vale
cero esto es cero y parte de aquí y
dicha recta va a ser simétrica dado que
estamos hablando de la raíz entonces es
para más dos tercios de equis y menos
dos tercios de equis y ahora si nos
vamos a la ecuación de la hipérbola y
vemos dónde intersecta al eje de las x
dicha ecuación podemos ver que sigue
vale cero y despejamos a x esto nos va a
quedar la raíz de 9 entonces es más tres
y menos tres y el punto más tres es lo
que estoy dibujando por aquí es esta
parte de la hipérbola y la otra parte de
la hipérbola y en el menos tres que se
vería por acá pero que ahorita no nos
importa analizar pues no está en la
circunferencia ahora bien ellos nos
dijeron que la hipérbole intersecta al
círculo en el punto a y b y dichos
puntos va a ser éste el a y éste de acá
él ve y la pregunta que nosotros tenemos
es que cuando la ecuación intersecte al
círculo en el punto a y b como diámetro
creo que puedo dibujar mejor dicha línea
recta
y ver como su diámetro de esa
circunferencia lo que tendríamos que
hacer es checar cómo la hipérbola
intersecta a este círculo y ver la forma
de realizarlo tal que nosotros podamos
encontrar las equis cuadradas del
círculo y sustituirla en la cuadrada por
aquí y así también encontrar con este
procedimiento su centro entonces hay que
figurar nos donde van a estar los
valores de jay y los valores de x
respecto a lo que tenemos de esta
hipérbola y estos puntos y b y así
encontrar la ecuación de dicha
circunferencia que vamos a buscar
entonces observemos bien esta ecuación
tenemos aquí x cuadrada más de cuadrada
menos 8 x igual a cero y bueno voy a
escribirlo por acá de color amarillo
sabemos que ye cuadrada de despejar esta
ecuación tendríamos que es igual a 8x y
pasamos la x cuadrada del otro lado
simplemente estamos despejando o si tú
quieres llamarle que añadimos o restamos
de ambas partes de la ecuación para
encontrar la y
es lo mismo y ahora vemos que en esta
ecuación de la hipérbola tenemos que es
x cuadrada sobre 9 - ye cuadradas sobre
4 igual a 1 lo que podríamos hacer es
que en lugar de ponerle cuadradas
sustituir este valor que tenemos de la
circunferencia por aquí arriba que sería
8 menos x 8 x menos equis cuadrada y con
esto hay que resolver nuestro problema
hay que visualizar cómo podemos
aprovechar dicha información y
resolverlo entonces aquí tenemos acá
abajo x cuadradas sobre 9 - y aquí ya
voy a comenzar a multiplicar por el
menos en este lado de la ecuación y a
dividir entre 4 entonces nos quedan
menos 2 x mas x cuadrada sobre 4
simplemente estamos desarrollando y esto
va a ser igual a 1 ahora también podemos
observar que 9 y 4 como factor común y
en el 36 entonces podemos multiplicar de
ambas partes de la ecuación para
eliminar las fracciones entonces 36
entre 9 tenemos que es 4x cuadrada
unos 36 x 272 x + 36 entre 4 es igual a
9 x cuadrada y todo esto es igual a 36 y
si ves estos términos que acaba de
subrayar de azul son términos
cuadráticas entonces los voy a sumar nos
quedan en 72 x y de este lado pasó el 36
y toda esta ecuación es igual a 0 y aquí
ya se ve claro que tenemos una ecuación
cuadrática entonces simplemente podemos
utilizar nuestra fórmula general y sacar
los valores de x entonces tenemos que x
va a ser igual a menos b pero en este
caso es menos 72 x menos uno de 72 más
menos la raíz de otra vez b al cuadrado
que es lo mismo que tener 72 x 72 menos
4 veces a que es 13 menos el 36 nos va a
cambiar el signo positivo y todo esto
sobre 2 a que 2
avn de haciendo 2 por 13 que sería 26 y
ahora quizás lo complicado ya aquí sería
reducir términos llegar a una a una
expresión más simple pero si observamos
tenemos mucho de dónde sacar tenemos por
acá que 72 por 72 pero a su vez es lo
mismo que si tuviéramos dos veces 36 por
dos veces 36 esto es lo mismo que 72 por
72 y vamos a agregarle la otra parte de
la suma que vendrá siendo x + 4 veces
por 13 por 36 y vamos a poner el 36
adelante para observar lo siguiente y
todo esto está dentro de la raíz ahora
si ves bien en esta parte de nuestra
raíz tenemos por un lado cuatro veces 36
de esta lado de la suma pero también
aquí 2 por 2 nos da 4 y también tenemos
que estar multiplicando por un 36
entonces me voy a extender un poquito
más para que quede mejor las cuentas y
tenemos que esto es la raíz vamos
simplemente a factorizar el término que
tienen en común estas dos partes de la
suma
tenemos que esto es 4 por 36 aquí está
multiplicando toda esta expresión
también a un 30
y esta parte de la suma está
multiplicando a 13 entonces aquí
simplemente factor izamos y ahora bien
esta multiplicación de 36 por 4 te va a
dar 144 y la suma de 36 y 13 es 49 ya
que ya no hay mayor problema porque
ambos términos o ambos números tienen
raíces exacta entonces tenemos que esto
la raíz de 144 es 12 y la raíz de 49 7 y
12 por 7 es igual a 84 entonces ya se
redujo tenemos entonces que x va a ser
igual a 72 más menos 84 y todo esto es
este término y todo esto sobre 26 pero
ahora también hay que observar una cosa
nos interesa que si le restamos al 72 84
nos queda un término negativo pero eso
está totalmente fuera de lo que nos
interesa saber de la circunferencia que
se encuentra del lado derecho entonces
vamos a sumarle nada más al 72 84 para
que nos quede un punto que esté dentro
de lo que nos interesa entonces 72 más
84 todo esto
no hay que dividir la hora entre dos
para que los reduzcamos un poco más es
36 más 42 sobre 13 y esto a su vez y 78
sobre 13 pero si es esta división si no
me equivoco 78 entre 13 es igual a 6 13
por 6 nos da 78 entonces esto es igual a
6 y ahora nos va a interesar encontrar
la otra coordenada del punto tenemos que
tenemos que x es igual a 6 entonces
simplemente ya es más sencillo y es
mucho más bonito encontrar el punto y
porque podemos sustituir el 6 en esta
ecuación que tenemos aquí tenemos que ya
cuadra desigualdad 6 por 8 48 y 6 al
cuadrado es 36 entonces vamos a tener
que ese cuadrado igual a 48 menos 36 y
esto va a ser 12 entonces lleva a ser la
raíz de 12 así que tenemos que nuestro
punto es 6 coma
la raíz de 12 podríamos simple esperar
aquí ya me equivoqué el 60 representa el
centro espero esto sea un tanto evidente
y el punto que acabamos de encontrar que
es el
a raíz de 12 es del punto a que tenemos
por acá arriba porque recuerda que
tenemos que es igual a más o menos la
raíz de 12 entonces el punto b va a
representar al 6,2 raíz de 12 y
prácticamente lo hemos hecho ya tenemos
nuestro punto a nuestro punto b y
sabemos que el centro es el 60 de dicha
circunferencia que acabamos de dibujar
entonces ahora hay que encontrar su
ecuación entonces vamos a trabajarlo por
aquí abajo tenemos que es entre 60
entonces esto va a ser igual a x menos 6
al cuadrado más menos 0 al cuadrado y
todo esto es igual al radio al cuadrado
y el radio viene siendo esta altura de
por aquí de la circunferencia o bien el
valor de jett que acabamos de encontrar
pero es el radio al cuadrado entonces si
es la raíz de 12 al cuadrado esto viene
siendo simplemente 12 y como está esta
ecuación ahora busquemos dentro de
nuestras opciones pero hace falta antes
desarrollar y ya entonces tenemos que
esto es igual a equis cuadrada menos 12
x 36 más cuadrada
a 12 igual a 12 pero hay que restar
ahora también de ambos lados 12 para que
nos quede igual a 0 la ecuación entonces
esto es igual a equis cuadrada menos 12
x más 24 más cuadrada igual a 0 y ahora
la voy a recortar y la voy a poner por
allá arriba para que logremos comparar
con nuestras opciones de respuesta
entonces la voy a pegar por aquí la
vamos a pegar y justo aquí la voy a
poner entonces si te das cuenta es x
cuadrada aquí está el término de la ye
cuadrada menos 12 x más 24 igual a 0 y
la respuesta con dichos términos en
menos 12 x más 24 y los términos cuadra
ticos es la a esa es nuestra respuesta
correcta y lo hemos hecho hemos logrado
encontrar nuestra circunferencia